I'm in Baikonur at the world's largest
spaceport or cosmodrome as it's cold
here in the middle of the Kazakh steppe
nowhere in the world launches as many
spacecrafts as this place does even the
Russian cosmonaut Yuri Gagarin the first
human in space took off from here
there are just a few hours left until
the launch a special train brings the
Soyuz spacecraft to the ramp
security is tight especially I was told
because there is a danger of espionage
and here it comes
the rocket the launcher at seven o'clock
in the morning right up until takeoff
technicians work in the rocket and
recheck everything meticulously because
the actual launch is one of the most
dangerous moments of the whole flight
obviously the launch is one of the more
risky phases but it's also something the
crew is really looking forward to to
experience these incredible forces that
push the humans from the surface of this
planet into orbit is remarkable the
g-loads
it's pretty quick less than nine minutes
from liftoff until you reach the
weightlessness and you are traveling
with almost 28,000 kilometers per hour
it's something to look forward to on
this flight to other astronauts are on
board alongside the German commander
Alexander Gerst with Russian Sergei
Prokofiev and the u.s. American Serena a
non Chancellor these two guys
really well our families know each other
well we spend time looking at at like
went over the weekend on trips around
Moscow in there that makes me completely
relaxed because I know that these guys
are fantastic they know their job and so
at nothing to worry about
the big moment is approaching and then
all systems are go everything is ready
for space